[Music]
my name is Mike Perry I've been with
broad cities since the beginning drawing
crazy typography and seen what kind of
animation explosions I can make for the
show he also has kind of become a visual
brand when I think about mushrooms it
fills you with warmth and positivity we
were thinking about the texture of
tripping the experiencing what it feels
like to trip so the first thing that
popped in my head was them walking
through this magenta pink Canyon with
just really warm glowing light that was
kind of like okay this is what its gonna
look like
even in the b-roll animations there's
like there's a guy's scape whirring
along the street but it's a blip in
cakes
he's on a pad of butter you know skating
on a pancake you know a bean alanna they
communicate with everybody we trust you
we believe in you do your work and
that's a rare creative relationship and
it's pretty damn special is it weird my
nipples are sore no that is perfectly
normal
mine is bleeding I really think that
watching this episode you really feel
like you're with the girls tripping with
them increasing the trip decreasing and
then like doing the stupid thing about
in weed too early it's like it's just so
weird is like no it's cool yes something
about our dynamic feels like it needs to
be captured and people are doing some
cool stuff online
what like a web series
[Music]